then I started researching it further
and I started to think does every person
deserve the right to vote did every
should every person deserve the right to
vote and what I found out is that men
are fined three hundred thousand dollars
if they don't enroll in Selective
Service where women have no skin in the
game and in the U.S anyways we're voting
for a commander-in-chief so is it really
fair that if I vote for a president
because of my feelings they know he's so
mean I'm not gonna name presidents and
instead I vote for somebody that's
basically senile and we go to war is it
fair that the men have to pay for that
bad decision